il ya bientôt dix ans j'ai passé un test
pour devenir prof de culture générale
dans un institut de préparation au
concours m'avait présenté une copie de
conques où l on m'avait demandé
d'estimer la note
j'ai dit que le fonds des dissertations
n'était vraiment pas terrible mais
qu'elle pouvait bien être noté 14 15
effectivement alors que les gens
pensaient qu'elle valait moins de 10 le
correcteur du concours l'avait noté 16
comment l'expliquer et bien la copie se
lisait facilement et comme je le répète
souvent
si vous écrivez clairement vous serez
sûr noté avant que je vous révèle les
trois secrets on doit se mettre d'accord
sur une chose qu'est ce qu'un bon style
comme vous écrivez une dissertation
votre style doit être bon pour le
correcteur qui est votre lecteur
et bien que veut-il le correcteur il
veut pouvoir vous lire très rapidement
et vous comprendre très facilement ça ça
sera possible si vous écrivez très
clairement le correcteur ne doit jamais
pouvoir résister en vous lisant aucune
ambiguïté ne doit l'arrêter votre
objectif c'est qu'il vous comprennent
instantanément conclusion améliorer
votre style en vue de la dissertation ça
veut dire le rendre très clair c'est un
moyen efficace de progresser rapidement
en dissertation
mais ça ne relève pas de la méthodologie
si vous voulez progresser en
méthodologie inscrivez-vous à mon cours
gratuits de méthodologie de la
dissertation souhaite en cliquant sur le
lien qui apparaît maintenant en haut à
droite de la vidéo soit en cliquant sur
celui qui est dans la description de
cette vidéo un cours par email donc
continuer de regarder cette vidéo puis
vous découvrirez montcourt méthodologie
après ou dans les prochains
là tout de suite ecoutez-moi
attentivement et vous serez précisément
quoi faire pour que vos prochaines
dissertation soit sur notre
moi aussi j'étais comme vous quand
j'étais étudiant je vous laisse
impressionner le correcteur donc
j'essayais d'employer des mots
compliqués du jargon philosophique ou
économique je me prenais la tête pour
créer des tournures littéraire et ça
donnait des phrases aussi longue que
compliquer et quel est le problème avec
cette tactique
le problème c'est que la complexité
c'est l'échec garanti
ça l'est encore plus en dissertation
parce que c'est un exercice avec une
contrainte de temps votre épreuve dure
un certain nombre d'heures donc vous ne
pourrez pas vous relire pendant des mois
donc le premier secret pour améliorer
votre style ces devises et la simplicité
vous devez tout d'abord viser la
simplicité sur le fond manipuler
exclusivement des idées que vous
comprenez et que vous maîtrisez ce que
vous expliquez dans votre dissertation
vous devez être capable de l'expliquer à
un ami comme l'a dit einstein si vous ne
pouvez pas l'expliquer simplement c'est
que vous ne le comprenez pas assez bien
bien sûr ça veut dire que c'est à vous
de faire l'effort de comprendre les
idées de la matière en amont en
préparation de votre épreuve de
dissertation ensuite vous devez aussi
viser la simplicité sur la forme
vous pouvez faire plusieurs choses pour
écrire simplement première chose
manipuler exclusivement des mots que
vous comprenez et que vous maîtrisez
éviter dans la mesure du possible les
mots techniques le jargon et préférez
les mots de la langue ordinaire voici
quelques exemples de simplification du
vocabulaire
deuxième chose que vous pouvez faire
pour écrire simplement préféré les
phrases courtes elles sont
statistiquement les plus claires et vous
risquerez moins d'être maladroit la
règle que vous pouvez suivre
c'est de mettre un point à chaque fois
que vous pensez à en mettre
n'hésitez pas à choisissez la sécurité
alors bien sûr il ne faut pas non plus
enchaîné les phrases ou trois mots mais
évitez les phrases longues
la troisième chose que vous pouvez faire
pour écrire simplement c'est de vous
passer des adverbes un adverbe c'est un
mot généralement variable qui nuance de
diverses manières le sens d'autres mots
vous devez surtout vous méfier des
adverbes en manque hommes
lentement extraordinairement
particulièrement 90% du temps c est vers
mena porte quasiment rien sur le plan du
sens et ils alourdissent la phrase
stephen king et les compare aux
pissenlits
si vous n'êtes pas vigilant vous aurez
des adverbes partout et votre
dissertation sera pénible à lire c'est
tout pour le premier secret souvenez
vous que pour écrire simplement vous
devez manipuler des idées que vous
maîtrisez employer des mots que vous
comprenez rédiger des phrases courtes et
éviter les adverbes allez on passe au
deuxième secret vous pensez qu'il vienne
d'où les mots que vous écrivez dans une
dissertation pourquoi croyez vous vous
choisissez telle tournure de phrase
plutôt que tel autre
eh bien c'est très simple vous écrivez
ce que vous avez déjà lu ou entendu
c'est une affaire de mimétisme
si vous lisez que des livres bourré de
jargon sociologique vous pensez que vous
écrirez comment vous aurez probablement
tendance à imiter les auteurs que vous
lisez donc à utiliser vos aussi du
jargon sociologique du coup pour écrire
clairement vous devez lire en priorité
les auteurs qui écrivent clairement
c'est ça le deuxième secret au fur et à
mesure que vous lirez les auteurs qui
écrivent clairement votre style
s'imprégnera progressivement des
qualités des styles que vous lisez c'est
pour ça que pour améliorer votre style
vous devez faire attention à ce que vous
lisez
maintenant sur quels critères faire
votre sélection
les correcteurs attendent un style
classique et plutôt simple donc vous
devez lire ce genre de style en français
le style classique se caractérise par ce
qu'on appelle le naturel ce qu'on veut
dire par là c'est que l'écrit réussir à
produire une impression qui rappelle la
spontanéité de la communication orale
quand on vous lit on ne doit pas avoir
l'impression que vous avez fourni un
effort c'est ça le naturel du style
classique la manière la plus simple de
développer cette qualité ce n'est pas à
décrire une thèse de linguistique mais
de lire les auteurs dont le style
possède cette qualité
après moi je ne vous recommande pas de
lire les meilleurs stylistes tout cas
pas tout de suite parce que le fonds ne
vous plaira probablement pas vous avez
donc plutôt intérêt à lire des choses
qui vous hante
un minimum et qui sont écrites dans un
style clair plutôt classique
je conseille généralement aux élèves
emile zola vous pouvez par exemple lire
au bonheur des dames sur les débuts de
la société de consommation
germinal sur la condition ouvrière et la
lutte sociale ou encore l'argent si vous
vous intéressez à l'économie et à la
finance
je conseille aussi stefan zweig même si
son style est moins simple parce que cet
auteur stimule bien l'intérêt du lecteur
et qu'il écrit tout de même clairement
si vous lisez spike votre style
deviendra plus littéraire ce qui n'est
pas une mauvaise chose
personnellement je vous conseille les
biographies de zweig celle de magellan
l'explorateur qui a réussi le premier
tour du monde ou celle d'écrivain
montaigne balzac dostoïevski ou encore
freud
enfin je vous conseille aussi de lire et
jack london un auteur américain
autodidacte parce qu'il a un style à la
fois simple et imagée et puis aussi
parce que ses romans se lisent
facilement pouvait lire martin edel qui
raconte l'accession de jack london à la
gloire littéraire où ces récits
d'aventurés qui sont à la fois réaliste
et des paysans parce que jack london
avait lui-même beaucoup voyagé voilà
j'en ai terminé avec mes recommandations
après le quoi j'ai une seule chose à
vous dire à propos du comment essayer de
lire un peu chaque jour faites en un
rituel elysées en étant très concentré
en faisant attention aux mots parce que
c'est ça qui vous permettra de vous
imprégner du style de l'auteur allez je
vous révèle le troisième et dernier
secret
que va-t-il se passer si vous essayer
d'appliquer les deux premiers secrets
lors de votre prochaine épreuve de
dissertation et bien vous serez très
lent vous saurez est ce que vous avez à
faire mais vous moquerez de pratique
c'est comme moi au tennis on m'a appris
à faire un bon coup droit et un bon
revers donc je sais ce que j'ai à faire
pour réussir ses coûts mais j'ai si peu
joué que je commet beaucoup de fautes
bon en fait c'est une règle universelle
quel que soit le domaine vous avez
besoin de pratiquer pour vous améliorer
pour améliorer votre style en
dissertation vous devez donc rédigé des
dissertations là vous avez peut-être
envie de me dire oui mais une
dissertation ça prend beaucoup de temps
on ne peut pas en faire une par jour je
le sais bien c'est pour ça que je vais
vous conseiller trois petits exercices
pour améliorer votre style le premier
c'est le plus rapide
vous prenez une de vos dissertation et
vous en lisez des passages très
attentivement en vous concentrant
exclusivement sur l'expression écrite en
vous lisant vous faites votre
autocritique vous essayer de détecter
les passages qui manque de clarté et
vous imaginez mentalement comment vous
les améliorant riez vous pouvez aussi
noté les choses sur votre copie si vous
préférez donc ce petit exercice c'est
comme si vous corrigiez vous même votre
expression écrite ça peut être très
rapide
si vous lisez qu'un ou deux paragraphes
par exemple le deuxième exercice
possible est un peu plus long
là vous ne vous contentez pas de
corriger mentalement un passage une de
vos dissertation vous leurrez écrivait
entièrement soyez exigeants ne vous
contentez pas de petites améliorations
transformer complètement le passage afin
de le rendre extrêmement clair enfin le
troisième exercice possible c'est de
rédiger une partie d'une dissertation
une fois vous avez traité un sujet avec
vous disposez d'un plan détaillé
plutôt que de prendre plusieurs heures
pour rédiger une dissertation vous
pouvez rédiger uniquement l'introduction
qui est la partie la plus importante de
la dissertation ou bien seulement un ou
deux paragraphes si vous voulez vous
entraîner à rédiger le développement son
troisième petit exercice est le plus
long mais vous en aurez généralement
pour moins d'une
mir donc si vous voulez vraiment
améliorer votre style en vue de la
dissertation vous pouvez faire cet
exercice
chaque jour et comme pour la lecture
vous avez intérêt à en faire un rituel
puis si jamais vous n'avez même pas 30
minutes pour vous entraîner et bien vous
pouvez faire un des deux premiers
exercices
à la place vous connaissez maintenant à
l'e3 secrète pour améliorer votre style
au dissertation vous devez lisez la
simplicité sur le fond comme sur la
forme
lire en priorité des livres dont le
style influencera positivement le vôtre
le rendra plus simple et plus naturels
et enfin vous devez vous entraîner à
rédiger des dissertations avec les trois
petits exercices que je vous ai suggéré
vous gagnerez facilement des points en
améliorant votre style avec mes trois ce
cas mais ça ne suffira pas pour réussir
vos dissertation pour ça vous avez
besoin d'une méthodologie solide
inscrivez vous donc à mon cours gratuits
de méthodologie de la dissertation soit
en cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit en cliquant sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo
voilà voilà comme d'habitude et j'espère
vraiment que cette vidéo vous sera utile
je suis romain je suis toujours avec mon
fidèle aristote qui dort encore et vous
étiez sur milliers de culture générale
rappelez vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
prendre la tête pour améliorer votre
style en dissertation
[Musique]